everybody what's going on welcome to
part 18 of our intermediate Python
tutorial series in this video what were
we talking about is decorators and what
they do so decorators as they sound
add decoration to your function you can
kind of think of them almost like they
wrap your function around so just as a
quick example you don't write this out
this is just an example of say a contact
page on a flask application in web
development with both flask and Django
decorators are pretty common at least
for me that was where I first really had
to use decorators and basically what
this does is you know you write your
function that does something it returns
this template this contact template and
then the beauty of using a web framework
is you can just use this decorator and
using this decorator it wraps this
function and basically add some code to
it that says okay when the user goes and
visits this URL we do the thing that the
this function we return this template
that's the contact template okay so just
a really quick example of where where
decorators are used in the wild now
let's actually talk about decorators and
and see how they work truly with example
so let's say let's say you've got a
function and this function is for a new
GPU and this GPU is we return a new
Tesla says p100 nice it's a nice GPU
Christmas's come in anybody want to send
me one of these just let me know I'll
give you my address next we've got we
could do print new GPU we can save and
run that oh we didn't run it laughter
there we go don't forget your
parentheses so we run it sure enough
it's a new GPU now since you guys are
sending it to me for Christmas maybe you
want to wrap the GPU so you might have a
new function and we'll say define add
rapping when you rap something your your
rapping right your rapping something so
you're gonna pass whatever the item is
that you want to rap into this rapping
function this will be our decorator
function and now we're going to say
we're gonna define raps underscore item
and what this is going to do is return a
a wrapped up box of something and then
we'll - dot format string version of
whatever the item is so so we return
that and then now at the that for the
actual ad wrapping function we're gonna
return wrapped item so now what we can
do is at new GPU we can wrap it so we
can say boom and wrapping and that will
decorate and our wrapping paper to our
new Tesla p100 GPU so we can now run
literally new GPU nothing changes we've
just added that wrapping with the
decorator so this is basically our
decoration we can run that and now what
we get is actually a wrapped up box of a
new Tesla p100 GPU thank you guys I love
your wrapping so what's nice is with
this wrapping functionality when you
have separate functions and also you can
all you can use this on like at class
methods and stuff like that you can use
it to all kinds of things so right you
could say define a new bicycle I don't
need one of these you don't need to send
me one returned but seriously on that
GPU I mean a new bicycle and we can wrap
that as well so we can act
rapping to that and then return int
rather new bicycle and you get wrapped a
box of a new bicycle okay so you can use
wrapping to do that kind of stuff now
what happens if you added wrapping to
the wrapping so you're one of these
people who like does boxes inside of
boxes to fool people what it is so for
example with the GPU the box will be you
know maybe about like this big or
something but you're one of these people
that puts it in a huge box and then puts
another box over it and stuff like that
so so maybe you would do you can do this
you can add wrapping so we'll just add
another wrapping or you could even have
you can put like another you could
create a new decorator function that's a
bow or something like that something
different than just adding wrapping
twice but anyway we can do the same
thing now it's wrapped up box over
wrapped up box of a new Tesla p100 GPU
but you could have created rather a
decorator function that was you know add
wrapping add bow and then have the box
or add bow at wrapping the box whatever
okay so you can do that kind of double
the double wrapping now one thing that
probably won't matter to most of you but
especially when you're using this
possibly with object or in your
programming and so on what if we said
print new GPU dot name so we're just
gonna grab the name of what should be
just like the function name basically
let's see what it says though instead
what were returned is wrapped I don't
because it's a it's actually a wrapped
item function now because what it
returns is this and in many cases you're
not gonna want that you're gonna want
that to actually return new GPU like so
if we do this right it's gonna say the
name is actually it's a new GPU function
right and so depending on what you want
maybe you actually want it to say this
because it is a wrapped item function as
well it's a wrapped item so that's true
but maybe you actually would rather this
be the the original function name what
you can do is you could come to the top
here
and from funk tools tools import raps
and that gives us that raps as a
decorator so we can say is a traps item
and then basically we change to nothing
else we'll save and run that and it's
the original function now so it doesn't
that name object or the the name method
rather won't book it overwritten if you
don't want it to again they're gonna be
times where well it is a wrapped item
right so so you you are gonna want to
override it but then there's gonna be
other times where but it's really
actually a new GPU I don't want to
overwrite that you could do that and
there's probably plenty of times where
you don't even care so do whatever you
want there now what we're gonna do is is
basically in case this function and
another function it's gonna be define ad
wrapping with style and we'll pass the
style and then we'll tab this over and
now we're gonna say a and then we'll do
some formatting and then over here we'll
say style comma string item so you might
say it nicely or a badly or whatever is
their return wrapped item and then we
come down here and actually we're gonna
return ad wrapping and that what we can
say as we can add wrapping let's say
Beautif so print new GPU save that run
that ad wrapping oh okay ad wrapping
with style whoops
a driving must run that again and now
what you get is a beautifully wrapped up
box of a new Tesla P 100 GPU and then
you could say like this now horribly and
now it's a horribly wrapped up box of a
beautifully wrapped up box of a new
Tesla P 100 GPU
okay so I think that's enough on
decorators but there's obviously a lot
of really cool things that you can do
and it kind of gives you a lot more
dynamic functionality to your functions
so it's actually pretty nice and also
methods too but I do like the added
functionality basically if that do not
repeat yourself that you can do with
this and still the dynamic Ness because
you can pass parameters obviously you
don't have to just use strings you can
use variables and all kinds of cool
stuff this is just meant to be a super
simple example but yeah pretty cool so
if you have questions comments concerns
something cool with decorators you want
to show let us know below although I'll
see you in another tutorial